but I guess more to what we're talking
about people that don't want to admit
like what about when it comes to like
Pinker's data about the world being a
better place because they have almost a
vested interest and stirring up fear and
they're committed that in their mind
they're committed to constantly studying
the the the wrongs of the world and the
evil of the world and that any sort of
diminishing of that is actually going to
cause harm to the people that are
suffering yeah I think they have a good
perp in their mind there's good
intention I totally agree yeah and the
data are consistent with their
strategies because on average fear
appeals and anger appeals work a whole
lot better than hey man things are great
donate to this cause and we'll keep them
great it doesn't work at all yeah and so
when when viagra was invented in 1989 my
little brother and I were chatting about
it we thought you know this will save
some animals because there's a lot of
animals that are consumed for their
presumed potency effects by like
traditional Chinese medicine consumers
and things like that and so we thought
boy if viagra actually works prior to
viagra nothing is out there that works
I'll bet this ll have an impact and so
we wrote this little letter off sent it
to a journal and said you know that this
is gonna save certain animals like seals
which they could be harvested to eat
their penises Canadian seals I know well
I know people that you're you're allowed
to kill a certain number you can't kill
the seals in America they're protected
but in Canada a US but in Canada you can
there's a hood seal a laminate allotment
and a harp seal allotment and so people
were killing up to their allotments and
selling you could do it solely for the
penis and sell the penis for enough
money to make your money back
now what purpose does the seals penis
have beyond the seals original purpose
zilch right but they eat it because it's
supposed to make you more potent rhino
horn rhino horn is an example that's
used for lots of different things so
it's less likely to be helped but the
seal penis is only you know people
basically only using your first potency
and then when fire comes along like
literally you're shopping in the
supermarket what you could have buy
you're gonna get I'll have some seal
penis or I'll take a Viagra well we just
said people are gonna switch we were if
you greedy you throw both yeah right try
them both and and people did actually
but but we we made this argument and we
literally were attacked by the World
Wildlife Fund government looking at plan
to revive seal penis what
hold the [ __ ] on is this recent it's was
update as published in 2015 but it was
updated this May what the government is
looking at a plan go back up to revive
seal penis sales okay this must be a
plan was brought to the government this
must not be the worst way of like
looking at that headline is that the
government's thinking man we got to
[ __ ] revive these penis sales no
one's buying seal but their mate because
they actually may be thinking that
because you got some relatively
impoverished people who are hunting for
them and no one's buying them anymore so
if you're not gonna whale that if you're
not real the report drafted by the fur
Institute there you go see is aimed at
creating new markets to support an
earlier proposal to kill a hundred and
forty thousand grey seals over five
years in the southern Gulf of st.
Lawrence 70 percent of gray seals that
frequent the area so they're what they
want to do is they want to diminish that
okay so here's what it is they have long
complained that the growing population
of gray seals is to blame for eating too
many commercially viable fish which has
resulted in repeated calls for a call
okay so they want to kill the seals so
to save the fish market so they're gonna
get people to buy dicks right so they
make it financially viable look at this
this is racist the penises of juvenile
adult animals may be dried and sold as
sexual enhancement products particularly
to Asian buyers well that's because it's
not meant to be racist is because in
traditional Chinese medicine the seal
penis was used as a potency product I
understand but the target those Asians
those poor fools well they're not
profiles anymore because you know what
they switched so we write this paper and
literally the World Wildlife Fund
attacks us and I did not see that coming
right I thought for the World Wildlife
Fund is gonna be psyched because here's
some good news for a change right but
they don't want good news they only want
bad news because people pay and they do
what they can to fix things when it's
bad news they and they forget that
you've got to have some good news along
the way or people give up look at this
this says here Asian consumers
particularly athletes also consume a
beverage called
honey say that dalla Shen oral liquid
that is made from seal penis and
testicles which they believe to be
energizing and performance-enhancing how
about some studies [ __ ] before
you
sealed dicks no why would you take that
when you can get [ __ ] by a grub
exactly guarantee of viagra's better it
is I mean if it's not better it's good
enough like what are you trying to do so
so we actually because we got attacked
by the world well of fun we sent one of
my Ida graduate student from Hong Kong
we descent him to go back to Hong Kong
for the holidays to go back to you well
the World Wildlife Fund because they
said that we're wrong people won't
switch they said what how would how did
they phrase it well they wrote an
article they rebutted us and they said
no no our data show when we tried to get
people to switch from rhino and tiger
horn to aspirin they wouldn't and so
they want yeah so they won't switch to
viagra and I'm like look I think fire is
different from aspirin I got a headache
I take an aspirin see I think my
headache got better faster than it would
have otherwise a little bit vague you
need a viagra you take it you're like
yep that sucker worked right there's
visual evidence and so we argue that
it's different and so we actually went
into these clinics and we asked people
in traditional Chinese clinics in Hong
Kong what do you take for a headache
what do you take for gout what do you
take for wrecked-tile dysfunction and
that was the one case where they'd
switched so consumers all over the world
they know when a better product comes
along they know when they've got no
options like well you might as well eat
a seals penis because that's as good as
anything or because nothing works maybe
you'll get a little bit of a placebo
effect or you know oh hey look there's
something that actually works that's
what I'm gonna buy when I read about the
one of the issues with rhino horn with
some Asian buyers is that also it's a
it's a signal of affluence that's
exactly right
yeah it's prestige purchase so sad [ __ ]
ever because that is such a crazy animal
the bizarre creature that almost seems
like a living dinosaur it looks it and
we're losing them left and right because
people are killing them for their
[ __ ] horn which is basically just
collagen right now it's fingernail yeah
that's bananas it just doesn't make any
sense to me that that is still that they
haven't realized that there's no value
in it there's no physical value it
doesn't really give you erections and is
it supposed to do fever it's got a long
list unfortunately
and they're still buying it and there's
nothing there buying it again yeah for
affluence like they get it exactly it's
like buying a Maserati wow that's so
crazy that's so sad
oh my daughter's outside the door hi get
out here you bother us yeah it's so
strange to me that there are these
specific cases right like it's not like
people are looking for giraffe horns
they're looking for rhino horn like what
do you think that they made an
association like damn if I was jack I
know those chicks are black me I need to
get that horn and eat it might get hard
like I do think so because if you look
at the long list of products they look
pretty phallic and mostly people eat
phallic things in order to gain potency
is there something crazy about seal
dicks like what's there decently sized
decent a good word for that I like that
and so you know you think oh I eat that
sucker I'll get big too right we're so
weird but it's so